bonjour à tous à suivre cet après-midi
elle est débats des sénateurs sur la
réforme pénale un texte qui a été adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale au début du
mois de juin et qui est examiné par le
Sénat depuis mardi en première lecture
et en procédure accélérée alors je vous
propose cet après-midi de voir les
meilleurs moments de la séance d'hier
soir alors notamment ce moment où les
sénateurs et le gouvernement se sont
opposés sur l'atténuation de la peine
qu'il faut prononcer pour les condamner
atteints de maladies mentales d'une part
il y avait les sénateurs de droite comme
de gauche après de nombreux déplacements
après de nombreuses études et de
nombreux rapports ils estiment qu'il
faut réduire d'un tiers cette peine en
cas de maladie mentales tandis que le
gouvernement lui y est opposé est opposé
à cette automaticité tout de suite donc
retour à la séance était hier soir au
Sénat
oui madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs c'est notre
dessinateur donc c'est un amendement qui
vise à supprimer un disposition qui se
trouve actuellement dans le texte de loi
c'est une disposition qui avait été
introduite à l'Assemblée nationale qui
avait prévu une atténuation de la peine
en cas de trouble mental
une atténuation à de moitié de la peine
nous avions trouvé le système rigide et
nous avons estimé que il est certain que
l'altération
de la raison est un motif pour que la
juridiction
apprécie la
détermination de la peine mais que fixé
à la moitié c'était une des rigidité qui
n'avait pas de pertinence donc nous
l'avions dit à l'Assemblée nationale
votre commission je crois que c'est sur
la proposition de
non c'est pas un amendement de Monsieur
Le Cerf mais c'est sur la base d'une
proposition de loi que le Sénat avait
déjà adopté c'est ça me semble-t-il donc
à proposer enfin vous avez introduit une
atténuation à un tiers de la peine
je veux dire que la logique de la
rigidité demeure la même donc pour cette
raison c'est un moment propose de
supprimer cette disposition tout en
maintenant dans le texte que
l'altération de la raison est un motif
d'atténuation de la peine merci madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur c'est
pas à vous c'est en discussion commune
monsieur rapporteur madame Benbassa vous
pouvez présenter le 64 ce sont des
amendements en discussion commune
excusez-moi monsieur le rapporteur
l'article 7 quinquiète a introduit par
la commission des lois concerne les
personnes dont le discernement a été
altéré au moment de la perpétration d'un
crime ou d'un délit et propose de
diminuer du tiers de la durée des peines
encourues nous souscrivons à cette
volonté mais considérons que la
juridiction doit tenir compte compte de
l'altération du discernement à la fois
lorsqu'elle détermine la peine et
qu'elle fixe son régime c'est l'objet
donc du présent amendement j'espère que
madame la Présidente vous décidez pas
non plus
autoritairement de mettre merci merci
Madame Massa je vais donc demander la
vie de notre rapporteur sur ces deux
amendements en discussion commune
alors ma dernière président de mes chers
collègues la commission aérienne avis
favorable je commence par là c'est plus
simple elle a maintenant 64 madame
Benbassa
92 bon la commission des Lois du Sénat
c'est ma proposition introduit dans le
texte exactement
la proposition de loi qui a été votée
ici à l'unanimité et qui résultait d'un
rapport d'information quel était fait
par la commission des lois d'affaires
sociales avec deux et deux le cerf et
moi Christian démontait et Gilbert
Barbier de ce rapport est sorti une
proposition de loi signée par le cerf
etc que j'ai rapporté ici qui a été
adopté unanimité contre la vie du
gouvernement je constate que les
gouvernements changent d'orientation
politique mais il ne change pas de de
service ou je sais pas qui a pu donner
un avis favorable la rédaction du
gouvernement est inacceptable elle est
très imprécise elle ne changera rien à
la situation actuelle donc cet
amendement est défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame le
ministre je vais vous demander
madame la ministre je vais vous demander
un avis sur l'amendement de Madame
Benbassa qui a reçu un avis favorable de
la commission
donc oui parce que c'est ça oui oui
c'est l'amendement que vous nez de
défendre en discussion commune c'est ça
et qu'est-ce que tu fais avec le mien
alors
pardonnez-moi madame la sénatrice mais
je soutiens plutôt le l'amendement du
Gouvernement
donc voilà
ça me conduit à émettre un avis
défavorable parce qu'on va pas écrire
des doublons dans la loi bien sûr sommes
d'accord donc c'est un regret le cœur
déchiré mais je veux un avis favorable
je le sens merci madame la ministre
monsieur le cerf pour explication de
vote
merci on avait présidente oui je vois
simplement resituer un petit peu le
contexte de de du problème qui se pose
ici j'avoue que je suis assez surpris
lorsque je lis dans l'objet de
l'amendement 92 une diminution
systématique de la peine du tiers c'est
pas de la moitié c'est du tiers par
rétro rigide et artificiel car elle
s'appliquerait quelle que soit
l'importance de l'altération du
discernement même en cas d'altération
très légère mais ce que l'on vit c'est
pas du tout des problèmes d'altération
très légères ce que l'on vit et ce que
le groupe de travail dont le rapporteur
vient de faire état avec constaté c'est
que 10% nous avions évalué effectivement
et je pense que notre évaluation est
faible nous avons évalué à 10% le nombre
de personnes détenues dont l'état mental
la l'état psychiatrique était-elle que
en ce qui leur concerne la peine d’avait
strictement aucun sens et que il n'avait
donc théoriquement pas grand chose à
faire dans les prisons de la République
si ce n'est transformé des prisons de la
République en du 21e siècle donc le
problème qui se posait était donc
et malheureusement si vous voulez
malheureusement je me félicite de la
franchise un certain nombre de
présidents de cours d'assises que moi
j'avais eu l'occasion de rencontrer à
l'époque de la loi pénitentiaire le
problème qui s'oppose c'est que il n'y a
pas de lieu d'accueil pour des personnes
dont le discernement est tellement
altéré qu'il confine à l'abolition pour
ne pas dire il est purement et
simplement aboli et on ne sait pas quoi
en faire ni ou les maîtres puisque il
n'y a plus de lipsychiatrique ou pas
suffisamment qui soit fermé et les
experts de ce principe pas non plus pour
estimer qu'il y a abolition du
discernement avec les conséquences que
cela aurait sur l'occupation de ces très
rares lits qu'est-ce qui se passe quels
sont les conséquences les conséquences
c'est que les cours d'assise vont donc
considérer comme ayant un discernement
altéré des personnes qui en fait ont un
discernement qui est aboli ou quasi
abolie et à cela explique d'ailleurs
avoir beaucoup de choses sur la
situation des prisons cela explique par
exemple le nombre particulièrement
important de suicide dans les prisons
françaises parce qu'on sait très bien
que les personnes qui ont effectivement
des problèmes très lourds en matière
psychiatrique ont une tentation
suicidaire qui peut être plus importante
que d'autres et le comble du comble
c'est qu'effectivement les principes qui
avaient été retenus par le législateur
d'avoir une appréhension différente
lorsqu'il y avait altération du
discernement c'était retourné contre
l'intérêt de ces personnes puisque ces
personnes dont le discernement était
altéré se voyait condamné beaucoup plus
lourdement que des personnes qui
seraient parfaitement saines d'esprit
d'où effectivement la volonté que nous
avions eu de faire en sorte que on ne
puisse plus se tromper désormais sur le
caractère de circonstances atténuantes
et non pas aggravante de cette
altération considérable confinant à
l'abolition je le répète du discernement
d'où la diminution effectivement d'un
tiers du montant de de du niveau de la
peine
et bien évidemment pour compenser le
fait que ces personnes se retrouvaient
plus rapidement dans la société était
prévu par le groupe de travail dans un
premier temps et de par la proposition
de loi dans un deuxième temps était
prévu le renforcement effectivement de
de des obligations de soins aussi bien
pendant la détention qu'après la
détention je crois que c'est un vrai
problème mais le fait que la preuve que
c'est un vrai problème c'est qu'il est
pas toujours fréquent avec une
proposition de loi soit adoptée à
l'unanimité et adopté à l'unanimité en
plus contre l'avis du gouvernement je me
souviens de cette séance un peu
particulier ou nous devions pas vraiment
l'impression d'avoir une une écoute
satisfaisante de la part de la
représentante du gouvernement de
l'époque donc moi je rejoins totalement
l'argumentation qui a été celle du
rapporteur de deux choses l'une soit
effectivement on essaye par le biais
cette fois-ci de de de cette loi en fait
de d'inscrire dans dans le texte
législatif l'essentiel de la proposition
de loi
soit la situation qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui et qui est d'une situation
qui n'est vraiment pas à l'honneur d'une
démocratie avancée comme la nôtre
continuera d'exister
merci Monsieur Le Cerf monsieur yes
vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente je pourrais
confirmer parce que l'avion constaté
l'état des prisons et combien il y a de
malades mentaux au graves pas du tout
des des gens un peu dérangés et des
souvent des criminels d'ailleurs pour
qui leur place n'est pas en prison et
moi madame le garde des sceaux vous avez
dit tout à l'heure j'avais participé à
l'élaboration du code pénal je me
souviens fort bien
la transformation de l'article l'ancien
article 64 qui est maintenant l'article
132,1 on avait on avait vraiment essayé
de dire parce qu'avant c'était l'état de
démence c'est pendant d'ailleurs lors de
l'acte commis c'est pas d'une manière
générale et on avait sous la citation
des spécialistes d'ailleurs on avait dit
soit abolition soit tes nations de la
responsabilité en fonction de l'état
mental
et depuis cette date
l'abolition il y en a pratiquement plus
les cours d'assises ne prononcent plus
l'abolition plus les gens sont plus les
gens sont malades mentaux et plus
et puis ils sont condamnés c'est quand
même le paradoxe alors qu'avant il y
avait un grand nombre de gens disaient
ils étaient en état de démence
irresponsabilités c'était l'époque aussi
où il y avait un certain nombre
d'établissements psychiatriques qui
accueillaient en milieu fermé
complètement on le sait Maison Blanche
enfin on pourrait citer un certain
nombre de d'établissements et puis
l'évolution de la psychiatrie en France
en France c'est pas vrai ailleurs a fait
que tous ces établissements ils ont été
ils ont disparus au nom de de principe
sans doute très intéressant et donc
comment résoudre cette question
vous dites madame le garde des sceaux
c'est bien on pourra en tenir compte
mais on devrait déjà en tenir compte si
on prend pas une mesure vraiment forte
et bien je crains bien que ça continue
comme comme aujourd'hui et donc le fait
quand il y a vraiment atténuation de la
responsabilité je crois qu'il faut dire
allez on diminue la peine
et en plus bien entendu il y a tout ce
qui va avec parce que c'est pas
seulement diminuer la peine c'est toutes
les soins etc en établissement
pénitentiaire et vous savez bien que
c'est difficile on connaît tous
l'établissement de Château-Thierry qui
est pas un hôpital mais qui est quand
même quelque chose comme ça dont on sait
mais qui est nécessaire à
l'administration pénitentielle dont je
crois vraiment que
le Sénat quand il a voté cette
proposition de loi en 2011 uneanime à
essayer de répondre
à une vraie question qui n'est toujours
pas résolue et honnêtement
votre amendement de ce point de vue est
totalement insuffisant c'est pourquoi je
soutiens la position de la Commission
merci chers collègues
je ne vois pas monsieur le monsieur le
Président sueur
oui
madame la présidente madame la ministre
moi je voulais tout simplement dire que
le travail fait par la Commission a été
très importante
le rapport qui a été fait
par Madame de montess par Monsieur Le
Cerf monsieur barbier et Monsieur Michel
et de haute qualité il y a eu beaucoup
de d'investigation
beaucoup de
d'auditions et nous sommes tous porteurs
de ce rapport et nous pensons
véritablement qu'il est nécessaire
de considérer qu'il y a une tant que
comme il y a quand il y a une altération
du dissertment se doit être un facteur
d'atténuation de la peine et voulons et
nous voulons le marquer fortement de
manière explicite et d'autre part madame
la ministre il va de soi pour nous que
cela doit aller de pair avec des
garanties concernant l'obligation de
soins pendant et après la détention
le président sueur je vais donc mettre
voir l'amendement 92 qui a été présenté
par le gouvernement et qui a reçu la vie
défavorable de la commission madame la
ministre vous voulez vous exprimer
madame le ministre vous souhaitez vous
exprimer non je vous en prie
le sujet est important je pense que les
sénatrices et sénateurs acceptent qu'on
passe encore un petit peu de temps je
vais pas m'éterniser là-dessus
simplement moi la préoccupation comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure la préoccupation
c'est c'est éviter une rigidité bon
j'entends l'argument en tout cas
l'argumentaire que vous avez développé
aussi bien monsieur sénateur le CF que
monsieur le Président yes je dis
simplement qu'il y a des situations
d'altération
plus légère qui ne justifierait pas
une réduction d'un tiers de la peine
alors j'entends quand vous dites que les
situations inquiétantes celles qui vous
préoccupent et qui nous préoccupe
parce que ces personnes vous avez dit
souvent des tendances suicidaires elles
ont aussi des tendances agressives et en
tout état de cause en milieu carcéral
leur situation s'aggravent donc il y a
danger pour elle-même danger pour les
personnels pénitentielles et danger
potentiellement pour la société parce
que quand ces personnes vont sortir
elles vont sortir dans un état de de
d'altération psychologique plus plus
importantes donc c'est c'est à prendre
en considération et c'est extrêmement
important mais moi ce que je crains
c'est que avec cette barre du tiers dont
je comprends la logique
il faut sortir de ce que vous avez
appelé cette
ce paradoxe ou la fragilité
psychologique de la personne je n'ai
plutôt de la peur aussi bien chez les
experts que chez les magistrats une
crainte de responsabilité si on atténue
la peine ou si on ne prononce pas une
peine d'incarcération et on est dans ce
paradoxe ou la peine prononcée
effectivement plus lourde donc je
comprends l'intention du législateur en
l'occurrence de vous de d'inverser
plutôt la logique et de dire que une
altération du discernement doit être
pris en considération en président
considération comme plutôt une
circonstance atténuante moi ce que je
crains c'est que en fixant la barre à
une réduction d'un tiers
le lorsque l'altération est légère
plutôt que de prononcer un tiers qui va
paraître trop trop forte réduction par
rapport au niveau d'altération que la
juridiction décide de ne pas en tenir
compte du tout moi c'est mon inquiétude
c'est mon inquiétude bon je la soumets
je suppose que dans les travaux que vous
avez conduit les auditions vos
réflexions vous avez vous en avez tenu
compte mais je veux vous soumettre ça le
risque me semble réel qu'on ne prenne
pas en compte une altération qui
justifierait une réduction moindre que
le tiers de la peine voilà alors que
cette altération est réelle et que est
justifierait
justifierait une prise en compte
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur je ne veux pas allonger les
débats qui sont déjà très longs mais
juste un mot d'abord c'est la peine
encourue qui sera réduite non pas la
peine prononcer et deuxièmement ça
dépendra du rapport d'expertise qui aura
été fait car dans ce cas-là il y aura un
rapport d'expertise psychiatrique bon
donc si l'altération est légère on a
entendu tous les psychiatres que la
France connaît plus est présents de
cours d'assises etc etc si la ration est
légère la conclusion sera qui n'a pas
lieu à prononcer c'est tout parce que
parce que le rapport d'expertise
conclura que voilà que ça n'a aucun
aucune répercussion je dirais sur le
fait de délinquance c'est tout donc je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de de soucis à
voir là dessus ce que nous avons fait
nous l'avons fait un tour de
connaissance de cause et après avoir
nous cette déplacé en Suisse en
Belgique etc etc et je crois que
personnellement je m'oppose encore à
l'amendement du Gouvernement merci
monsieur le rapporteur je vais donc
mettre vous à l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
ce qui est contre
merci abstention
merci
l'amendement n'est pas adapté
l'amendement je vous vois la Mondement
64 qui a été présenté par notre collègue
madame Benbassa qui a reçu le favorable
de la commission et par voie de
conséquence des favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
merci qui est contre
abstention l'amendement 64 est adopté
voilà vous l'avez vu les sénateurs ont
donc gain de cause sur l'atténuation de
la peine en cas de maladies mentale ils
ont adopté cet amendement des cerven
bassasnatrices écologiste et ont ensuite
adopté l'article qu'il soit de gauche
comme de droite on passe tout de suite à
un autre moment clé de la séance d'hier
soir l'article 8 terres consacré à
l'autonomie de la contrainte pénale
cette peine qui est l'une des mesures
phares du projet de loi il y a d'une
part le gouvernement qui veut que ce
soit une peine alternative que les juges
puissent prononcer pour tous les délits
qui sont passibles de 50 prisons ou
moins une peine qui peut être une peine
alternative à la prison d'autre part il
y a le point de vue du rapporteur
Jean-Pierre Michel qui lui veut que
cette peine soit la seule peine qui
puisse être prononcée pour un certain
nombre de délits tout de suite retour au
débat
nous arrivons à l'article 8 j'ai une
demande de parole de notre collègue
André Richard
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l'article 8
ter que nous allons examiner maintenant
vise à faire de la contrainte pénale une
nouvelle peine autonome
celle-ci ne serait donc plus au terme de
cette proposition un aménagement de
peine elle remplacerait purement et
simplement les peines de prison pour un
certain nombre de délits à savoir sous
réserve de ce que nous dira monsieur le
rapporteur tout à l'heure le vol simple
et le recel de vol simple la filouterie
la destruction la dégradation ou la
détérioration ne présentant pas de
danger pour les personnes le délit de
fuite le délit d'usage de stupéfiants le
délit d'occupation des hauts l'immeuble
et les délits prévus par le code de la
route
je voudrais dire ici d'emblée que le
groupe UMP y est très défavorable pour
plusieurs raisons la première nous
sommes saisis de cet article 8 ter à la
suite d'une proposition d'amendement
monsieur le rapporteur que la commission
des lois prouvé par une voix de majorité
or cet article qui ne figurait pas dans
le texte initial et d'une telle
importance pour le dispositif pénal dans
sa globalité qu'il nous semble qu'il n'a
pas donné lieu à suffisamment de
réflexion pour nous engager dans la voie
proposée car de fait c'est ma deuxième
raison en remplaçant la peine de prison
pour certains d'élits tels que proposés
dans certains cas d'ailleurs des délits
puni jusqu'à 3 ans d'emprisonnement quel
signal donnons-nous d'une part ou
délinquant et d'autre part à nos
concitoyens
dans la mesure où la contrainte pénale
apparaît comme un concept flou j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure les termes de
sanctions à géométrie variable utilisée
dans dans le débat c'est un signal
d'impunité que l'on va donner au
délinquant quant à nos concitoyens alors
même qu'il s'agit de restaurer la
confiance qu'ils ont dans leurs
institutions est-ce bien le moment de
nous engager dans une voie qu'il ne
comprendront pas et pour cause puisque
tout simplement cette voie n'est pas
claire
qu'on le veuille ou non dans notre pays
la peine de prison structure le système
pénal
elle est un symbole qui imprime dans
l'esprit de chacun la gravité de l'acte
qui viole la loi en abaissant comme veut
le faire cet article 8 ter l'échelle les
pen on marque d'une part une sorte de
renoncement et on touche d'autres parts
à la structure de l'échelle des peines
qui on en est je pense tous conscients
ici n'en a pas franchement besoin j'ai
bien compris à cet égard que Madame
Lagarde des Sceaux avait confié une
mission à Monsieur cote pour revoir
l'échelle des peines dès lors est-ce
bien le moment d'anticiper les
conclusions de cette mission ce que
demande la société c'est une sanction
adaptée à la faute dans une échelle des
peines juste et compréhensible et dans
cette échelle la prison trouve bien
entendu encore sa place
pour autant comme cela a été dit au
groupe UMP nous ne sommes pas arc-boutés
sur le tout carcéral et nous
encourageons vivement le recours aux
aménagements de peine quand c'est
possible celui-ci a d'ailleurs largement
progressé ces dernières années comme la
rappeler tout à l'heure notre collègue
le président yes dans son intervention
en discussion générale mais nous semble
que ces aménagements de peine doivent
s'associer à la crainte d'une peine
privative de liberté qui ont constituent
le préalable le condamné peut se voir
condamner à une peine de prison qu'il
pourra voir ensuite transformer avec ou
sans délai en aménagement de peine si le
magistrat le pense souhaitable
à cet égard on peut même considérer que
la contrainte pénale instaurer en peine
autonome
constitue constitue en fait une vraie
contrainte imposée au magistrat qui ne
pourront plus apprécier la personnalité
du délinquant dans le contexte de la
faute qu'il a commise enfin
pourra-t-on avec cette nouvelle sanction
pénale mettre fin à ce que monsieur le
Président yesth appelait tout à l'heure
le scandale de l'inexécution des peines
empêchera-t-on pour autant sérieusement
ou freinera-t-on la récidive on sait
bien que les deux phénomènes sont dues
pour l'essentiel à l'absence de moyens
on ne fait pas assez dans ce pays pour
l'approbation et la réinsertion or cette
contrainte pénale ajoutée aux
aménagements de peine qui vont encore se
développer va nécessiter beaucoup de
moyens madame la garde des sceaux nous a
indiqué quel moyen elle comptait
mobiliser pour accompagner ce projet de
loi acceptons-en l'augure mais je crains
fort que de la même façon que la grande
loi que constituait la loi pénitence
pénitentiaire de 2009 qui n'a pas trouvé
les financements adéquats pour permettre
sa pleine et anti-rapplication à
l'instar de cette loi je crains qu'il en
soit de même pour ce nouveau texte que
vous vous apprêtez à voter aujourd'hui
la situation des finances publiques mes
chers collègues s'imposent à tous que
l'on soit de droite ou de gauche et
c'est pas à la veille une discussion sur
le projet de loi de finance rectificatif
que je dois le rappeler dans cette
hémicycle pour toutes ces raisons je
suis David qu'il ne faut pas voter cet
article 8h et je vous remercie de votre
soutien à cet égard
merci chers collègues je suis saisie de
trois amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement numéro
13 c'est Monsieur buffet qu'il présente
monsieur Richard enfin il est défendu
madame le Président je viens de faire
une prise de parole à cet égard qui
était assez claire merci chers
collègues
cet amendement est le même que celui de
notre collègue Richardt nous arrivons
avec l'article 8 ter du projet de loi si
je puis dire au cœur des modifications
qui ont été proposées par notre
rapporteur et qui ont été adoptés en
commission avec ces dispositions
nous avons purement et simplement la
Commission a purement et simplement un
instigation du rapporteur modifié la
nature même de la contrainte pénale en
effet la contrainte pénale nous était
présentée comme une nouvelle possibilité
qui était offerte au juge en complément
des possibilités déjà existantes
d'accroître sa liberté de choix et de
trouver la réponse la plus adaptée
avec l'article 8tr tel qu'il a été
introduit par la commission c'est tout
le contraire c'est tout le contraire cet
article supprime la peine de référence
actuellement en vigueur qui est
l'emprisonnement et c'est pas nouveau
qui est de longue date d'emprisonnement
qui pour toute la population et la peine
de référence pour imposer
dans un certain nombre de cas la
contrainte pénale je dis bien imposée
puisqu'il n'y aurait plus le choix ça
serait
obligatoirement la contrainte pénale ou
rien
et on porterait ainsi atteinte à la
libre appréciation du juge alors que au
contraire et c'était dit dans l'exposé
des motifs de cette loi cette loi a
aussi pour
objectif de compléter la gamme des
réponses que le juge peut apporter un
délit
le système
proposé fait donc disparaître la peine
de prison
on aurait pu imaginer qu'elle perdure au
moins encadrécidive mais non elle ne
perdure pas même en cas de récidive 5 6
7 récidives de détérioration dégradation
et l'emprisonnement ne pourra toujours
pas être prononcé par le tribunal
correctionnel on peut donc pas faire
abstraction du message qui est envoyé à
nos concitoyens lorsque l'on décide de
supprimer des peines d'emprisonnement
pour une série de délits même s'il nous
est proposé maintenant de sortir de
cette liste le vol et le recel de vol
mais je dois dire que aujourd'hui il y a
7 cas
où cette peine aurait pu être
appliqué en concurrence avec
l'emprisonnement on sauvegarde le délit
de vol simple et recèle de vol simple
mais les six autres cas
tombe sous le coude de la proposition
du rapporteur donc là il nous semble
qu'on donne un message très mauvais à la
population et au délinquant en puissance
monsieur le rapporteur votre proposition
avec l'article 8 ter n'est pas
acceptable et je dirais les pas
acceptable pour trois raisons que je
tire d'ailleurs de l'amendement déposé
par Madame Lagarde des sceaux elle
procède une confusion sur l'objectif et
le contenu de la peine de contraintes
pénale elle complexifie la répression et
elle aboutit finalement à un
affaiblissement de la répression nous
partageons pleinement l'analyse de
Madame la Ministre et donc nous
proposons de supprimer l'article
si chers collègues madame la ministre je
vous invite à présenter l'amendement 98
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur effectivement le gouvernement
souhaite supprimer cet article que vous
avez introduit
je me suis exprimée à l'occasion de
l'audition de mon audition devant vous
en commission des lois
en vous rappelant on vous indiquant que
la logique de la conception de la
contrainte pénale est-elle liée à la
nécessité d'assurer un suivi de l'auteur
de l'infraction et que
cette conception liée à la contrainte
pénale donc à la personnalité qui
justifie ce suivi qui n'existe dans
aucune ni dans les alternatives
à l'incarcération ni dans les
possibilités d'aménagement de peine vous
changez la logique ce qui se conçoit
mais vous changez la logique puisque
vous
vous référer vous faites la contrainte
pénale se référer à des types
d'infractions
je vous ai expliqué effectivement comme
le rappeler monsieur le sénateur Richard
que
nous avons je suis d'accord qu'il y a un
maître de l'ordre dans dans le droit des
peines et c'est pour ça que cette
mission a été confiée au
président Bruno cote
il y a donc il y a cela le fait que pour
nous la contrainte pénale et les liée à
la personnalité au profil qui mérite ce
suivi très très ajusté qui s'adapte qui
s'intensifie qui s'allège selon les
besoins et qui s'évalue
et vous vous l'alliez à une liste
d'infraction ensuite
il y a le fait que
lorsque vous liez à cette liste
d'infractions
disons en y mettant des guillemets qu'il
s'agit de petites infractions d'accord
or la contrainte pénale c'est pas une
petite contrainte pénale en fait c'est
pas une petite peine que nous sommes en
train de mettre en place nous sommes en
train de mettre en place une peine
spécifique dans sa composition
et qui doit donner des résultats parce
que elle est conçue comme devant assurer
un suivi le plus proche possible donc
sur ces deux points
concevez une contrainte pénale qui n'est
pas de la même logique ne relève pas de
la même logique que la contrainte pénale
que le gouvernement introduit dans ce
texte de loi
ensuite il y a quand même parce que je
regardais la liste peut-être qu'il est
bon pour éclairer l'ensemble de des
sénatrices sénateurs de rappeler la
liste des infractions que vous avez
prévues si vous voulez avoir l'amabilité
de me
repasser parce que nous pensons qu'il y
a d'autres infractions qui auraient leur
place éventuellement dans
cette disposition qui consiste à exclure
des infractions de toute peine
d'emprisonnement parce que c'est ça
votre démarche c'est faire en sorte que
sur certains de d'infraction les peines
prononcées puissent être
quelques peines qui existent déjà dans
notre code voilà et où la contrainte
pénale alors je rappelle que la
contrainte pénale comme elle est conçue
justement
pour suivre
elle est contraignante donc c'est un
dispositif qui est relativement lourd ça
durait minimale et de six mois
il y a un certain nombre d'infractions
pour lesquelles il n'y a pas nécessité
d'un dispositif aussi lourd alors vous
n'en faites pas une réponse exclusive
donc dans certaines situations
effectivement la juridiction pourra
prononcer autre chose notamment un
travail d'intérêt général c'est pas la
bonne peur ah si pardon
un travail d'intérêt général ou autre
chose mais il y aura des situations où
le travail n'intérêt général ne
correspondra pas soit la situation de la
personne soit sa personnalité soit à ses
capacités
ou le stage de citoyenneté peut-être ne
sera pas la bonne réponse et où
finalement la contrepénal sera prononcée
peut-être pour toute en toute premier
acte
peut-être pour une personne
pour un acte où il y a une relative
dimension accidentelle une personne qui
qui n'est pas en train de s'installer
dans la délinquance mais qui dans des
circonstances particulières a commis
donc voilà ça me paraît à ces moments là
ce sera vraiment le mar Teau pour
écraser la mouche donc dans ces
circonstances là dans ces cas là la
contrainte pénale sera trop lourde
la délai que vous avez retenu donc je
crois que vous avez supprimez la
commission supprimer le vol simple
par contre il reste la filouterie
la destructions dégradation et
détériorations qui ne présentent pas de
danger pour les personnes commises sans
circonstances aggravantes le délit de
fuite le délit d'usage de stupéfiant le
délit d'occupation des meubles les
délits prévus par le code de la route
alors là on a un vrai sujet vous savez
que nous travaillons avec le ministère
de l'Intérieur vous aviez envisagé et
nous aussi la commission de Nadal par
exemple l'avait envisagée aussi nous
avons réfléchi à la contrevention
contraventionnalisation de certains
déliroutiers et à la question bien
entendu du risque de relâchement de
vigilance s'il y a cette affichage
d'abaissement des peines par rapport à
la liste que vous avez donnée il y a
quand même quelques infractions qui
justifieraient que les peines qui
peuvent être prononcées ne soient pas
des peines d'incarcération
par exemple certaines blessures
volontaires par exemple la violation de
domicile c'est-à-dire l'occupation sans
titre ou son droit de domicile par
exemple abandon de famille pour
l'instant ce sont des infractions qui
donnent lieu à des enfin qui sont punis
dans notre code pénal potentiellement
par des peines d'incarcération et qui
seraient justifiées
d'exclure de la possibilité de prononcer
des peines d'incarcération donc je pense
que contenu de ce que je vous ai dit sur
les deux éléments qui divergent par
rapport à l'approche et à la conception
que le gouvernement a
qui qui a inspiré le gouvernement pour
la contrainte pénale compte tenu du fait
que justement la nécessité de refendre
le droit de la peine et qui s'exprime
par le fait que vous choisissez un
certain nombre d'infractions qu'on peut
concevoir que certaines d'ailleurs
vous-même vous avez estimé que certaines
devaient en être exclus puisque votre
commission a supprimé le vol simple que
moi je peux vous vous dire que il y en a
qui pourraient y être incluse
je pense que peut-être il est prématuré
de
d'introduire cette disposition bon je
suis pas sûr de vous avoir convaincu
malgré tous les efforts
assez évident manifeste presque physique
que j'ai accompli pour vous expliquer
cela mais voilà la position du
gouvernement et évidemment j'attends en
grande sérénité le vote de votre
assemblée
la ministre monsieur rapporteur donc la
Villa commission sur les amendements la
Commission des doigts a émis une avis
défavorable à ces trois amendements
puisque elle a voté majoritaire
majoritairement
le nouvel article 8 ter pour quelle
raison
cet article 8h monsieur Richard ne vient
pas de rien
ils viennent de loin
il vient pour ce qui nous concerne en
France d'abord de la préconisation 36 du
rapport de monsieur rimbours qui dit
créer une peine de contraintes pénale il
s'agirait d'une peine principale se
substituant à l'emprisonnement pour
certains délits
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai voulu faire
j'ai fait ce que à la suite des
auditions nombreuses que nous avons
faites en commission des visites que
j'ai faites à la Cour de cassation la
conférence de consensus c'est pas
prononcé vraiment
pas vraiment mais l'idée c'est que la
contrainte pénale est une peine autonome
qui se substitue à la peine
d'emprisonnement voilà et que en matière
délictuelle on doit être sur un
triptyque la prison la contrainte pénale
les peines pécuniaires et peine
pécuniaires pour que cette triptyque
existe il faut bien que concurrent
ce que propose le projet de loi on
prévoit c'est un début mais la mécaneso
si vous voulez allonger la liste tous
vos amendements seront les bienvenus
qu'on prévoit pour un début que pour un
certain nombre de délits la peine de
prison n'est plus encourue c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je me
suis opposé et la commission m'a suivi à
ce que en 2017 il y a basculement
automatique vers tous les délits
car je pense qu'en 2017
le bilan il devrait être fait aussi sur
cette tactique 8 ter ce qu'il est
maintenu comme je le souhaite et cassons
là on verra ce qu'on fait de la
contrainte pénale et à quel délit on
pourra l'appliquer de façon autonome
sans peine de prison je veux mettre dans
la tête de l'opinion publique des
magistrats etc qu'il y a trois sanctions
possibles et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
les nombreuses auditions que nous avons
faites presque toutes presque toutes ont
été d'accord avec cette position je
passe sur la commission consultative
droits de l'homme je passe sur
l'audition très forte de Robert Badinter
à cet égard je passe sur l'audition de
Madame Mireille danemarkti je passe sur
l'audition du rapporteur de Madame
professeur Herzog Evans je passe sur
l'audition de Monsieur le Professeur
Xavier pin etc etc
et donc voilà pour les raisons pour
laquelle j'ai proposé tarticuite terre
qui est prudent
il est tellement prudent d'ailleurs que
j'ai entendu ce qui a été dit en
commission des lois notamment par
Jean-René le cerf sur et par aussi Yves
des trains sur le vol disant bon là
c'est un mauvais signal le vol le volcan
ça peut être autant le vol du
microsillon ou du rouge à lèvres dans un
magasin mais aussi le fourgon plein
d'argent bon c'est vrai donc j'ai retiré
le volcel si vous voulez qu'en mettre
les délits de famille abandon de famille
etc on peut les rajouter voilà mais le
principe je veux l'introduire dès
maintenant dans la loi la contrainte
pénale est destinée à être une peine
autonome
pour revoir l'échelle de pndi et pour un
certain nombre de délits et je pense
qu'il faut le dire maintenant j'aime
beaucoup les commissions elles sont très
bien elles sont précisées par des gens
qui sont des amis qui sont excellents
mais ils remarque qu'elle débouche très
peu sauf la conférence de consensus pour
l'instant et donc prenons comme
fondement comme base ce projet de loi et
introduisant d'ores et déjà cette petite
idée que la paix de contraintes pénale
est une peine autonome pour laquelle
pour les délir auxquels elle s'applique
les la peine de prison n'est pas en
couple voilà quelle est la philosophie
de l'Antiquité qui ne révolutionnera pas
je crois votre droit pénal mais qui à
terme à terme c'est vrai si le bilan de
2017 le démontre est destiné à aller
plus loin
madame madame la ministre
madame madame madame la ministre par
cohérence par cohérence je peux
considérer que vous êtes favorable aux
deux premiers amendements puisqu'ils
sont identiques aux autres
l'amendement 13 et l'amendement 29
rectifié c'est les amendements de
suppression
je croyais qu'il fallait être favorable
à un seul
dans ce cas si c'est un seul je suis
favorable à l'amendement du Gouvernement
s'ils sont rédigés absolument ah bah oui
c'est des suppressions c'est de
suppression
j'en profite pour dire parce que je
crois qu'il faut en tout cas moi je sens
que moralement dans ma tête je dois
assumer cela parce que je le pense je
pense qu'il y a un risque il n'y a
absolument pas l'intentionner parce que
d'abord travaillons depuis suffisamment
longtemps pour connaître votre esprit je
connais votre démarche connaître je
connais votre philosophie et en plus tel
que vous présentez les choses il n'y a
aucun risque au niveau de l'intention
aucun doute possible mais lorsque nous
observons dans le passé ce qui s'est
passé c'est que la tendance la tendance
est à la gravation de la répression
c'est à dire que il est quand même
possible que là où aujourd'hui en
prononce des stages de citoyenneté ou
des travaux d'intérêt général ou il est
quand même possible que en prenant de la
contrainte pénale on l'a vu notamment
avec le bracelet électronique
lorsqu'il est arrivé c'était censé la
surveillance électronique était censée
apporter une solution essentiellement
d'aménagement de peine donc d'exécution
d'une sanction en milieu ouvert et on
s'est rendu compte que le bracelet
électronique a été utilisé dans un champ
plus large et que on a eu plutôt une
descente
par rapport au niveau d'infraction donc
une sanction un niveau
relativement lourd de sanction qui a
touché des infractions qui étaient plus
basses donc moi je le dis je le dis je
me trompe peut-être complètement mais
la contre pénale qui est une sanction
lourde et ceux qui disent qu'ils n'ont
que c'est un aménagement etc non c'est
tel que c'est conçu c'est une sanction
lourde
ça a duré c'est de six mois à 5 ans
c'est une sanction lourde les
obligations sont plus larges que ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui dans le sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve les interdictions
pareillement
l'exécution est immédiate l'évaluation
se fait de façon immédiate et elle
renouvelée régulièrement
donc la contrainte pénale est une est
une vraie peine avec ses contraintes et
c'est lourdeur donc voilà moi j'attire
l'attention
parce qu'il arrive qu'on ne fasse pas
enfin que ce qu'on produise n'est pas de
quoi sont pas absolument à ce qu'on veut
faire j'attire quand même l'attention
sur ça voilà je le dis donc évidemment
je donne un avis favorable à moi-même en
l'occurrence
du gouvernement et concombitament
puisque l'occasion est offerte de vous
être agréable
vous me le revaudrez merci merci Madame
la Ministre la parole est à Madame
cuckermann pour une explication de vote
oui
je crois que
j'entends ce que vous dites madame la
ministre et sur le fond
je le partage après je crois que faire
de la politique et c'est aussi parfois
faire preuve de pragmatisme je crois que
sur cette question et notre rapporteur
la bien expliqué le souhait de la
commission ce n'était pas
d'affaiblir
cette cette nouvelle sanction qui est la
contrainte pénale mais au contraire de
lui donner de la visibilité et éviter
finalement que au-delà de l'affichage
législatif législatif elle soit
réellement utilisée mise en oeuvre dans
les différentes juridictions et c'est en
ce sens que nous avons
suivi soutenu pardon
l'amendement du rapporteur et que et que
se tiendront finalement la rédaction en
l'état de l'article 8 ter alors
j'entends
les risques que vous pointez
je crois qu'ils sont à mettre en ballon
aussi si je peux si nous pouvons nous
exprimer ainsi sur effectivement
un autre risque qui serait celui
finalement de
l'appauvrissement voire de la de
la réduction à la portion la plus
congrue de l'utilisation de la
contrainte pénale parce que par facilité
par tradition d'usage
elle serait finalement très très peu
utilisé très très peu mis en oeuvre et
nous nous pourrions nous retrouver en
2017 avec une utilisation assez faible
si je dis cela c'est parce que
les choix de la commission les choix
issus du vote de l'Assemblée nationale
en séance plénière non pas fait que la
contrainte pénale soit élargie à tout à
tous les délits je reviens pas au débat
que nous avons eu précédemment un
certain nombre de de critères de de
contraintes si j'ai envie de dire à la
contrainte pénale ont été ont été
validés par l'Assemblée nationale et que
dès lors il nous semblait important et
en tout cas intéressant à travers la
rédaction de cet article 8h de pouvoir
avoir sur un certain nombre de délits
identifiés
la suppression de la peine de prison et
du coup la contrainte pénale avec les
autres alternatives également proposées
que ce soit cet ensemble là qui soit en
tout cas proposé à l'appréciation des
juges donc voilà moi j'entends ce que
vous dites je crois aussi voilà mais
vous vous l'avez très bien dit
qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait de malentendu
en tout cas entre nous alors peut-être
que les uns les autres donc ils ont pas
les bons arguments mais je crois qu'en
tout cas la volonté des uns et des
autres c'est que la contrainte pénale
réussisse et qu'effectivement on puisse
sortir
de ce système la seule sanction qui
vaille dans notre pays serait la case
prison quelle que soit finalement le
délit donc voilà en tout cas à ce jour
il va y avoir une CMP mais je ferai
peut-être comme certains de mes
collègues le regret que nous soyons en
procédure d'urgence et finalement je
crois que sur ce point-là mais comme sur
d'autres une deuxième lecture aurait pu
être bénéfique et enrichir approfondir
le texte et donner tout le sens à ce que
vous aviez initialement souhaité donc
voilà je crois que d'ici la CMP on peut
encore essayer d'avancer et de
travailler pour trouver la solution la
meilleure possible
chers collègues madame le ministre
monsieur le Président la Commission mais
sur la portée en mes chers collègues
j'ai le plaisir de vous informer que la
France est qualifiée pour les huitièmes
de finale et qu'elle affrontera le
Nigéria
la parole est à notre collègue monsieur
le monsieur buffet je pense qu'elle n'en
est la parole
le ministre moi je une fois des pas
coutumes je volerais bien à votre
secours
car
à l'instant non non c'est sérieux à
l'instant où nous parlons je ne sais pas
où est la vraie contrainte pénale
il y a celle proposée par le
gouvernement par vous-même
comme une alternative à la détention
qui s'applique à des délits ou des
crimes en tous les cas des infractions
des délits pardon à des infractions ou
une peine de prison est encourue
et que dans ces conditions là
face à cette peine encourue il y a une
liberté de pouvoir dire et de choisir la
contrainte pénale c'est effectivement
dans ce cas là une vraie alternative qui
est offerte une possibilité de faire
et puis dans le cas de cet article dans
Le discutons il y a plus
cette peine encourue de détention elle
disparaît puisque la contrainte pénale
devient une infraction une sanction en
dehors de tout autre référence contenu
de la liste des faits qui sont visés
que se passe-t-il et je suis d'accord
avec vous je suis donc en désaccord avec
la proposition faite par le rapporteur
c'est que la notion de peine encourue
est un tout hypothèse à l'égard des
délinquants potentiels
un message fort qui est envoyé pour dire
en cas de commission de tel ou tel
infraction vous risquez la prison et
nous savons ensuite que devant le
tribunal le magistrat la liberté de
choisir
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu'il y a un risque réel en supprimant
avec cet article le fait qu'il n'y ait
plus de peine de prison encourue de voir
une évolution
importante dans l'échelle des peines qui
existent aujourd'hui sur notre dans
notre droit pénal et de voir les
comportements délinquants parfaitement
changé car il n'y aura plus cette
crainte potentielle de devoir aller
exécuter une peine en détention c'est la
raison pour laquelle
nous voterons évidemment d'abord notre
amendement cette fois-ci par préférence
mais si la devenait un funeste
destin sera Liré au vôtre à ce moment-là
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Richard
parce que je me suis exprimé tout à
l'heure sur sur cet article mais c'est
l'intervention de monsieur le rapporteur
qui me fait réagir finalement monsieur
le rapporteur vous souhaitez inscrire
cette contrainte pénale comme peine
autonome
dans le code pénal vous le disiez
finalement
en principe comme un principe vous
souhaitez introduire cette contrainte
pénale entre d'une part les les
sanctions financières enfin bon amende
pour être plus clair et puis la peine
d'emprisonnement
et je dirais presque on vous entendant
peu importe les délits qui sont
concernés par cette contrainte érigée en
peine autonome vous nous dites ce matin
sur la base des propositions faites par
certains de nos collègues membres de la
commission j'ai renoncé
à inscrire cette peine pour le vol
simple moi je n'étais pas en commission
ce matin parce que j'étais retenu
ailleurs mais j'ai appris ça tout à
l'heure donc voilà on considère que
soudain le vol simple n'est plus
punissable de cette contrainte pénale
mais donc va retomber dans dans
la règle de droit commun donc
l'emprisonnement juste question pour
pour m'informer parce que quand même on
va voter là tout à l'heure est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du recel de vol
simple enfin bon y a-t-il bon et puis
vous dites même à madame la ministre
vous dites même à la ministre si vous
voulez en rajouter d'autres bah écoutez
rajoutez-en non attendez on est on est
en là on est en droit pénal est-ce qu'on
peut quand même franchement il s'agit
pas d'ériger un principe il y a des gens
qui vont tomber sous le coup de cela
je sais pas la société nous regarde on
on quelle image donnons-nous quelle
image donnons-nous excusez-moi de de
cette impunité de de quel délit comment
enfin moi j'estime excusez-moi pour être
je reprends mes termes à moi mais
j'illustre un peu ce que voulait dire
madame la ministre si elle l'autorise
cette affaire n'est pas mûre excusez-moi
de dire comme ça elle n'est pas mûre
pourquoi ne pas attendre effectivement
dans la mesure où une mission a été
donnée
à un professeur cote de de
réfléchir à une échelle des peines dans
dans ce pays et on en a besoin tout le
monde le sait on a besoin pourquoi on
attendrait pas et on laisse au rôle de
contrainte pénale
enfin la contrainte pénale le rôle que
le gouvernement
il voyait si tentait que vous le
souhaitiez et que ce soit voté par le
Parlement à savoir
une substitution à une peine
d'emprisonnement pour les raisons que
vous souhaitez bien que je sois pas tout
à fait favorable à ça pour empêcher la
la récidive
la parole est à Monsieur capocanella
oui merci la présidente une fois n'est
pas coutume effectivement je reprends la
formule nos vues convergent
nous avons sur ce point ponctuel un
point d'accord nous pensons que les
dispositions introduites par la
Commission et tente fortement elle est
fait de la mise en oeuvre de la
contrainte pénale les tentes trop et tu
la notion d'expérimentation la notion de
progressivité la notion de recherche de
l'alternative à la prison sans
s'interdire que la prison puisse être
également une option c'est ça la
difficulté
et c'est comment faire un pas plus loin
après la loi pénitentiaire sans se
priver aussi de la solution
ultime de la prison et la liste des
délits qui est jointes même
délester si vous me passez ce mot
tes vols et des recettes de vol
ce dont il faut donner crédit aux
rapports d'avoir eu
ce matin
le courage et l'honnêteté de présenter
cet amendement qui est positif mais même
délaissés de ces deux délits la liste
induit que pour une série de délits le
risque de la prison n'existe plus
il faut sans doute considérer que la
prison est un élément fort qui n'est
mise en oeuvre que dans des cas extrêmes
pour autant sans passer c'est aussi
donner un signal et donner un signal
potentiellement à des auteurs à des
auteurs multirés en disant pour cette
catégorie là de délit
jamais vous ne risquez la prison
c'est quand même un signal fort pour les
victimes
c'est encore plus un signal mais cette
fois un signal d'abandon de la société
qui donne le sentiment que
l'infraction le délit qui vont subir
n'aura pas forcément une réparation
n'aura pas forcément une sanction aussi
forte
que auparavant avec la prison alors
autant on peut entendre et qu'il faut
développer des alternatives à la prison
autant empêcher le juge en fonction de
la personnalité
d'individualiser la sanction et en
fonction des circonstances aussi
l'empêcher de choisir soit la contrainte
pénale soit l'emprisonnement ça nous
paraît un signal manifestement excessif
et puis je veux dire que dans ces sujets
extrêmement difficiles et on peut
passionnel il nous faut faire preuve de
pédagogie et vous nous proposez un pas
important je pense qu'il est dénaturé là
si on franchit à l'étape qui nous est
proposée
la parole est à Madame
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais un peu dédramatiser le débat
que nous sommes en train de mener sur
cet article 8 ter alors j'entends bien
les interrogations les inquiétudes
exprimées par le gouvernement et il est
dans son rôle notamment par rapport aux
interrogations que nous avons tous sur
ce que peut être la compréhension de
l'opinion par rapport à une réforme
comme celle-ci mais enfin
je ne crois pas que cet article 8 ter
marque une rupture avec la logique de la
loi que nous examinons il ne change pas
la nature
profonde de la contrainte pénale
d'ailleurs madame la ministre vous avez
bien dit vous-même la contrainte pénale
est une peine est une vraie peine et une
peine lourde donc on ne change pas de
nature et une chose qui est la rue et
que qu'on oublie peut-être d'évoquer ce
soir dans toutes les auditions très
nombreuses auxquelles a procédé le
rapporteur et pour ma part j'en ai suivi
un très très grand nombre il est apparu
que la majorité des acteurs de la chaîne
pénale
s'interroge sur la réalité de cette
contrainte pénale il se pose tous des
questions mais qu'est-ce que c'est où
est-ce que ça se situe dans dans
l'échelle des peines comment ça va se
traduire concrètement et moi je pense
que notre rapporteur s'efforce en nous
proposant ce pas de plus de donner une
réalité à la contrainte pénale et
justement de de définir un champ qui
permettra de mieux
toucher la réalité de la contrainte
pénale il le fait d'une manière qui
reste tout de même relat malheureusement
modéré puisque il a lui-même suggéré de
restreindre la liste des délits
passibles de contraintes pénales sans
être passible de l'emprisonnement en
supprimant en effet le vol et le Russell
je rappelle aussi qu'il s'agit de délits
dans tous les cas sans atteinte physique
aux personnes ce qui est tout de même
fondamental donc c'est un champ qui
reste modeste et je rappelle que nous
sommes tous en interrogation sur
l'utilité de la prison c'est le point de
départ d'ailleurs de la réflexion que
nous menons tous ensemble et que vous
avez fort bien mené madame la ministre
nous sommes en interrogation sur
l'utilité de la prison donc il faut bien
un moment qu'on qu'on mette les mains
dans le cambouis sur ce sujet et me
lancer force d'apporter une réponse dans
la loi par la loi à cette interrogation
profonde sur l'utilité de la prison
alors je crois quand même que le constat
il est très largement partagé non
seulement un sur le fait que ça n'est
pas toujours une sanction efficace mais
même quel produit des effets contraires
à ce que l'on recherche c'est à dire
tout de même
l'harmonie sociale l'arrivée à ce que
après le délit il y est une une
voie suivre pour ne pas plonger
forcément dans la prison donc moi je
crois que la proposition demeure modérée
maintenant je sens bien toutes les
interrogations toutes les réticences je
dis simplement qu'il serait bien de ne
pas dramatiser sur ce sujet et d'en
faire un affrontement mais plutôt
peut-être d'utiliser le peu de temps qui
nous reste d'ici là d'ici là commission
mixte paritaire si le texte devait être
adopté
donc le temps qui nous restera pour
essayer de tirer profit de la
proposition que nous a fait leur
rapporteur sans forcément
considérés qu'il y a là une
contradiction frontale avec l'esprit de
la loi je pense que cette réflexion
mérite d'être menée
la parole est à Monsieur dutrègne non
merci
Monsieur le cerf
oui merci madame le Président je crois
effectivement qu'on est sur un moment
important de la discussion et je n'ai
jamais regretté autant la procédure
accélérée je dois connaître que dans un
premier temps ça ne m'avait pas trop
choqué il y avait eu la même procédure
utilisée pour la loi pénitentiaire et ma
foi nous étions parvenus à discuter
malgré tout de manière approfondie de
votre pénitentiaire mais je crois que la
contrainte pénale elle apporte un
élément qui est un élément beaucoup plus
novateur et je comprends effectivement
que
le rapporteur est beaucoup de nos
collègues soit convaincus que si on
n'arrive pas à autonomiser cette
contrainte pénale elle risque
effectivement de ne pas jouer du tout le
rôle que nous sommes à certains nombres
à souhaiter que cette contrainte
puisse jouer donc on se trouve
réellement un peu entre le le marteau et
l'enclume je voulais simplement ajouter
aussi une chose supplémentaire c'est que
comme étant rapporteur du budget
d'administration pénitentiaire je visite
assez souvent les établissements
pénitentiaires je crois que on se fait
aujourd'hui de la prison comme peine
ultime une fausse idée il y a
aujourd'hui deux catégories de personnes
qui fréquentent par donnez-moi
l'expression les établissements
pénitentiaires des personnes que je
qualifierais de classiques pour qui
cette effectivement la pire des peines
et ce sont des personnes que la prison
peut d'ailleurs totalement briser mais
il y a à côté de cela toute une autre
catégorie de délinquants qui sont des
lacs qui ont peut-être plus jeunes
peut-être davantage issus de de banlieue
peut-être ayant effectivement des
problèmes de rupture scolaire ayant des
difficultés à se considérer comme
intégrer dans notre République pour qui
parfois la prison est un épisode d'une
forme de de maréchalade d'adélinquance
dont ils pourront quasi ensuite se
vanter et je pense que pour ces
personnes là qui sont des personnes qui
créent justement une situation
d'insécurité ou un plus qu'un sentiment
une véritable situation d'insécurité
pour de nos concitoyens la contrainte
pénale les obligations les interdictions
le suivi
personnalisé s'y suivi il pourrait y
avoir et on rejoint le problème des
moyens que nous avons effectivement
évoqué à de nombreuses reprises il
serait finalement beaucoup plus lourd et
il serait ressenti comme étant un
inconvénient une charge beaucoup plus
forte que les la prison traditionnelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
m'éloignais un petit peu de l'opinion de
de mes collègues et amis de mon groupe
sur ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
oui je voulais rajouter un certain
nombre d'éléments mais qui viennent
d'être excédé d'amandis par notre
collègue le Serge sur le sens de la
contrainte pénale et le message qu'on
fait passer aussi aujourd'hui tantôt
délinquant actuel ou aix-futur si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi qu'à la société
c'est pas parce qu'il n'y a plus de
prison c'est pas parce qu'on prononce la
contrainte pénale comprenant ce quelque
chose qui est une non sanction la
contrainte pénale peut être beaucoup
plus lourde à vivre et à survivre que
que la prison donc je crois qu'il faut
on parlait je crois que c'était monsieur
Richard tout à l'heure qui parlait de la
France au regard faisons attention à ce
que l'on dit oui faisons attention à ce
que l'on dit la contrainte pénale est
une véritable sanction et il n'y a pas
d'impunité quand on prononce la
contrainte pénale alors qu'autrefois on
prononcer la prison on a récemment ici
même créer un nouveau délit qui est le
délit d'entrave à l'action du contrôleur
général du lieu de privation de la
liberté qui est un délit qui n'est pas
puni de prison donc on a déjà commencé à
aller dans ce sens là de délit qui
éventuellement ne peuvent pas être
prononcés ne peuvent pas être
sanctionnés pardon par de la prison et
je voulais aussi quand on a parlé des
auteurs on parle de la société on a
parlé des victimes aussi tout à l'heure
et je pense que même du point de vue des
victimes il est important de se dire que
parfois il n'y aura pas de prison
prononcé on le sait c'est souvent un
facteur qui retient des victimes de
portée plainte quand elles sont victimes
de d'un proche de la famille d'un ami
d'un conjoint etc on sait que ça retient
souvent la victime de porter plainte que
de se dire qu'en portant plainte elle va
envoyer l'auteur en prison et si cette
victime elle sait demain qu'il existe
une autre sanction qui est la contrainte
pénale qui va être efficace et qui
n'envera pas l'auteur des faits en
prison on va peut-être là aussi plus et
mieux aider les victimes que ce que l'on
pensait et enfin ce n'est pas parce
qu'un article qui créerait une
contrainte pénale sans possibilité
d'emprisonnement pour certains certains
délits que la contrainte pénale
disparaît totalement pour autant de
paysages pour les autres délits elle
reste pron onçable donc il y a pas
effectivement là il dichotomie profonde
et effectivement profitons de ce temps
qui nous reste qui est encore court
jusqu'à la CMP mais profitons-en pour
peut-être continuer d'affiner
la parole est à Madame Benbassa dernier
intervenant inscrite après monsieur le
président
merci cher collègue pour tout ce que
vous avez dit
c'est vrai que qu'il nous reste de temps
et qu'il faudrait peut-être être
pédagogue si on nous entend il faut
qu'on soit pédagogue et qu'on passe un
message clair et compréhensible moi je
pose la question simplement il faut
expliquer que la prison ne règle pas la
question la récidive alors elle la
prison n'est pas actuellement pour les
délits dont nous parlons efficace et que
la contrainte pénale pourrait se révéler
en tant que peine
disons indépendante
elle pourrait se révéler efficace
tantôt le coup voilà je n'ai je ne sais
pas c'est un message clair les gens
comprendraient bien que la que la la
prison
reproduit la récidive nous avons des
chiffres la ministre va donner des
chiffres tous nous avons auditionné des
gens et le constat est la multiplication
la récidive alors voilà c'est un message
clair je ne sais pas pourquoi nous nous
torturons tant
sur cette question à cette heure-ci et
surtout que nous avons un message à
transmettre merci
madame benmassa monsieur le président
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je me suis inscrit
quand l'un de nos collègues monsieur
Richard précisément a envoyé le mot
impunité
avec une exposé que qui était très clair
vous nous avez dit chers collègues
finalement ça va être l'impunité
or je ne sais pas combien de fois nous
avons expliqué lors du débat général que
nous étions contre l'impunité
et que comme nous étions contre
l'impunité nous pensions que tout délit
méritait sanction mais que si l'on
voulait que toute sanctions soient une
référence à la prison ou la prison et
bien on y arrivait pas et que ce n'était
pas réaliste ne serait-ce que parce
qu'il y a aujourd'hui je le rappelle
selon le dernier chiffre connu
99600 peine de prison ferme qui sont
décidés et qui ne sont pas mis en oeuvre
donc il y a au moins 100 000 personnes
qui se baladent
alors qu'il y a eu des décisions de
prison ferme et d'autre part nous savons
très bien que pour les délits qui a
énuméré notre rapporteur
le plus souvent si prison il y a où il y
avait où il y aurait
ce serait des courtes peines et que les
courtes peines de prison ont des tas de
conséquences
d'abord on sait que c'est par rapport
aux courtes peines qui a le moins
d'aménagement
le moine préparation de la sortie et
puis il suffit de visiter une prison
pour voir que c'est l'occasion pour un
certain nombre de personnes d'entrer
dans un milieu
et on sait bien que les peines autre en
particulier la contrainte pénale sont
plus appropriées sont meilleures alors
voilà tant qu'on aura dans la tête que
peine égale prison et que si on met en
oeuvre une alternative la contrainte
pénale ce sera toujours quelque chose
qui fera moins peur en quelque sorte
donc ce ne sera pas une vraie peine
c'est celle ce cette centralité de la
prison dans le système avec laquelle il
faut rompre et avec laquelle nous avons
rompu dans la loi pénitentiaire où la
prison est définie comme le dernier
recours
comme ça quoi on fait appel en matière
correctionnelle si il n'y a pas eu
d'autres solutions donc cette ce débat
de ce soir est essentiel il est
important c'est un changement de culture
soit nous l'assumons soit nous
l'assumons pas nous avons choisi de
l'assumer parce que nous connaissons
trop les
inconvénients du système actuel on n'est
pas dans comme si tout allait bien
et comme si tout allait se détériorer
parce qu'il y aurait la contrainte
pénale
donc voilà il y a un choix c'est un
choix important par rapport auquel nous
allons nous déterminer
merci monsieur le Président je vais donc
mettre vous à les trois amendements
identiques
aux voix un avis défavorable de la
commission et favorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci mes chers collègues abstention ces
amendements ne sont pas adoptés on
arrive à la maman 108 qui doit être
présenté par la commission Monsieur
Michel
le corps d'une erreur la correction
d'une erreur de coordination
c'est matériel c'est matériel la vie du
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
n'est pas rancunier c'est un avis
favorable merci
je mets je mets aux voix cet amendement
je mets aux voix cet amendement qui
visiblement est une erreur matérielle
qui est pour
merci contre abstention la maman est
adopté le 118 Monsieur Michel au nom de
la commission des lois il a déjà été
largement fait quoi cette amendement ou
je propose de supprimer dans la liste
des délits pour lesquels seul la contrée
pénale est encourue avec la peine prison
ou les peines alternatives le délit de
vol et de recettes de vol je vous
remercie la vie de la ministre contenue
du débat que nous venons d'avoir madame
la Présidente la ville du gouvernement
et la sagesse je vous remercie mais je
mets aux voix cet amendement sagesse du
gouvernement de la commission sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour
merci qui est contre abstention
l'amendement est adopté madame ku Kerman
le 82
très rapidement puisque même si notre
rapporteur fournit un excellent travail
il nous semble qu'il a omis dans cette
liste
les délit de conduite d'un véhicule sans
permis et donc nous pensons que dans la
logique que nous avons longuement disque
nous venons discuter il serait bon
d'inclure les délits pour des lits de
conduite d'un véhicule sans permis
merci Madame Kerman la ville de la
Commission
qui est mon cardinal de Richelieu
grise sur cet amendement
compte tenu également va rester cohérent
bien entendu je veux simplement attirer
l'attention sur ce sujet parce que la
question des délais routiers est une
question qui a un peu qui est devenue
complexe les délires routiers
représentent 42% des jugements condensés
en correctionnel c'est considérable et
nous avons il y a des incarcérations qui
sont liées qui sont qui punissent des
vies routiers donc évidemment
nous avons envisagé parce que l'élan est
tout à fait logique envisagée de
contraventionnaliser comme je disais
tout à l'heure les délai routiers mais
le sujet extrêmement sensible le sujet
extrêmement sensible parce que les
comportements eux-mêmes sont sensibles
à à la fois l'ambiance c'est au niveau
de sanction donc nous faisons très très
attention nous travaillons je vous l'ai
dit la commission Nadal a travaillé sur
le sujet nous travaillons avec le
ministère
de l'intérieur mais nous savons qu'il
faut voilà être très prudent sur sur ces
délits là parce que il y a quand même
une dimension psychologique qui
intervient dans les comportements et qui
n'est pas négligeable donc voilà je
voulais juste attirer l'attention là
dessus et bien entendu
la vie du gouvernement c'est un ami de
sagesse contenu du long débat
que nous avons eu tout à l'heure je vous
remercie madame la ministre je mets aux
voix l'amendement 82 présenté par
pendant que Kerman avis favorable de la
commission sagesse du gouvernement qui
est pour
merci qui contre
merci chers collègues abstention merci
l'amendement est adopté nous arrivons à
vote sur l'article 8 ter qui est pour
voter l'article
merci qui est contre
merci chers collègues abstention
l'article 8 ter est adopté
voilà pour les débats consacrés par les
sénateurs hier soir à la réforme pénale
débat qui se sont conclus aux alentours
de minuit et demi avec l'adoption de cet
article 8 ter un des articles les plus
importants du projet de loi vous l'avez
vu les sénateurs ont beaucoup réécrit le
texte ont beaucoup radicalisé ce texte à
l'initiative du rapporteur socialiste
Jean-Pierre Michel les discussions
devraient reprendre cet après-midi aux
alentours de 16 heures et le vote il a
certaines adaption du texte devrait se
tenir ce soir dans l'hémicycle vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site sur public
sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 18h pour les
questions cribles au gouvernement qui
sont consacrés à la pollution de l'air
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires